just the other day the partners at my
firm pulled me aside and they were
visibly upset about something that I had
done
a portion of this video is sponsored by
vesi more on them later in this video
you made a decision that we didn't all
agree on and you were not being
transparent about this honestly I did
speak to everyone individually
hey guys my name is dammy and I'm an
architect in beautiful Vancouver BC when
I got that feedback I cried no I'm just
kidding
um I I had a lot of bad emotions I you
know I had done my version of what I
thought was right and it really felt
like I was being accused of being a bad
architect and even a dishonest person as
I kind of progress into my career and
also as I kind of build my YouTube
business I've been getting criticism of
all kinds including ones like this and
it's been really challenging to manage
So lately I've been learning a lot about
how to deal with criticism and feedback
more effectively so today I want to talk
about some of the things that I learned
from the book thanks for the feedback in
the first part of the video I'm going to
talk about how to receive that feedback
and in the second part of the video I'm
going to talk about how to navigate that
feedback conversation and how to
implement that feedback into your lives
and in the atrium this is where you have
your communal gatherings
it's a pretty model but
um
I don't think you're quite capturing the
essence of the library as an institution
the ontology of the library you know a
library is an Institutional history
[Music]
and you expect people to just sit around
here like that
handling feedback on your project is one
thing and handling feedback on your
performance or your voice that's a whole
nother thing and in fact it is really
important for you to categorize the
different types of criticism so there's
three types of feedback there's
evaluation that's where you talk about
where you stand in relation to the
expectations and to other people there's
coaching or advice which is all about
helping you improve and I think a crit
or like a performance review is probably
somewhere in between those two there's
also appreciation or recognition or
thanks which basically lets you know
that you're doing well and that your
efforts are being noticed so when you're
asking for feedback you actually want to
be fairly clear on what you're looking
for just two prevent confusion or
conflict from both parties the hardest
part about receiving feedback is
actually the emotional response and it's
the emotional response which makes us
angry or defensive and a lot of the
times we can get dismissive of that
feedback but if you identify what
triggers those emotional responses you
can have much better control over those
reactions dealing with criticism can
take a toll on you for me whenever I
feel overwhelmed I like to go outside
and spend some time in nature but
sometimes we don't always have dry
weather or dry land that's why today I
want to talk to you about Bessie vessi
shoes are 100 waterproof they're stylish
and comfortable so you can wear them
wherever you go it's made from dime
attacks which is a dual climate knit
material that keeps you cool in the Heat
and warm in the cold but the the best
part is it really doesn't feel like the
kind of shoes that would be waterproof
they're super comfy they hug my feet
they're extremely lightweight and
they're breathable
I love how I can wear them all season
around and I literally wear them
everywhere these are the only pair of
shoes I need to pack and they're so
versatile and functional and if you're
someone who lives in a rainy climate
Bessie is a great investment in your
closet get 25 off for each pair at
vesi.com damily generally there's three
types of triggers there's the truth
triggers so truth triggers are responses
to feedback we feel is wrong or
unhelpful or unfair but as we know
everyone has their own idea of the truth
so the very very first thing you want to
do is instead of thinking no that's
wrong or oh well that makes sense for
you but not for me you have to
acknowledge that everyone thinks
differently and even if it's hard try to
ask yourself like what is right about
what the other person's saying at the
same time try to examine yourself for
any blind spots in your thinking there's
Behavior patterns so we often have
behaviors that are totally unknown to us
but others they see it really clearly a
really good example is using filler
words like
ums or us or like
um
like that because they've been so
embedded into your speech pattern that
you don't even recognize that you do it
and for me I only recognize that I do it
a lot when I started making videos on
YouTube and another blind spot is
typically like you judge your actions by
the intent and others judge your actions
on impact and especially how it impacts
them and paradoxically when we come into
challenging situations we tend to
attribute it to the circumstance but
other people tend to connect it to our
character so it's come to my attention
that you made a decision on the glazing
frame colors that we didn't all agree on
and you are not being transparent about
this and if this keeps happening this is
the fastest way we're going to lose
trust in you
I had to make that call I was already so
late on getting back to them and I
couldn't wait another week for us to all
meet and honestly I did speak to
everyone individually and my
understanding from the conversation was
that we were all aligned on picking
white we also have tells that we might
not be aware of like facial expressions
or voice and any other like non-verbal
behaviors or like habits that can say
the opposite thing of your intentions
there's also emotional Distortion when
our emotional reaction to something is
like way out of proportion to the
content of the feedback you can find
some of these blind spots by observing
how you get really defensive or
recording yourself you can also look for
patterns in the feedback like if you're
getting the same feedback from different
people you know that's issue and the
second type of trigger is relationship
triggers which is an emotional response
to the person more than the content of
the feedback so there's two main types
of relationship triggers one is our
opinion of that person so when we get
negative feedback we are subconsciously
looking for ways to disqualify that
person from giving that feedback and
then number two is how they treat us so
if you feel like they're not
appreciating you or your efforts or you
feel like they don't have the authority
or you you might just feel like that
person doesn't really like you and in
situations like this a very common
response can be for us to respond with
something that's like aimed at the
person rather than the issue itself and
when this happens it will split the
conversation into and you just start
talking talking about two completely
different things so for example your
roommate will say oh you're so messy and
you'll say something like oh yeah but
you're so loud like you leave the TV on
until 2AM and I can never sleep and so
it's very important for you to recognize
this and actually address each one of
these topics separately before they turn
into bigger problems and sometimes the
conflict might not even be happening
because of you or the other person but
because we're all a part of this system
that defines our relationships and you
might have different values or habits
and you might have different roles in
the relationship so sometimes just like
stepping back and like looking at the
whole system as a whole can be really
helpful the next one is identity
triggers
and these ones are a big one identity
triggers can happen when the feedback
doesn't align with your sense of who you
are or the story that you tell about
yourself for me like when I got that
feedback from my bosses uh part of the
reason why it stung so much was because
it was an identity trigger and you were
not being transparent about this and if
this keeps happening this is the fastest
way we're going to lose trust in you I
felt like it was an attack on my
integrity and my capability as a person
and as an architect and you know I
consider myself to be a very transparent
person and that's kind of one of the
things that I take a lot of pride in and
so my emotional response was probably
kind of exaggerated
compared to the issue at hand and I
think the best way to deal with identity
triggers is just like adopting a growth
mindset a person with a growth mindset
seize their traits as evolving
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
door window architecture
but if you have a fixed mindset you will
see your abilities as stable and
finished
my voice is my personality stop watching
my videos and there's actually ways you
can develop a growth mindset by
listening to feedback as coaching rather
than evaluation or judgment it's more
about like how you're doing things and
what you're doing rather than on you
also don't worry so much about how this
is affecting the other person's opinion
of you you know in the end it's really
hard to change people's opinion of you
but it's really easy for you to change
how you reflect on yourself so just try
to focus on that also whenever you get
feedback try to evaluate yourself on how
you're taking that feedback like if you
can handle that feedback better than
others then appreciate yourself for that
because that in itself is a really
positive trait that actually very few
people have identity triggers are
probably one of the most emotional out
of all of these so try to monitor your
emotional reactions thoughtfully by
trying to control your emotions or even
better like trying to separate your
emotions from the facts I also have my
own kind of strange strategy for this so
whenever I'm in a bad situation or I get
back feedback I imagine myself as like a
character in a comedy movie or in a
sitcom
and I just kind of proceed to deal with
the issue at hand yes it is important to
adopt a growth mindset but there are
certain things that are just like
outside of your control like how others
feel about you and especially after you
do your best to remedy the situation if
they still have a negative feeling
towards you just let it go and just try
to be Zen about it because it's a waste
of your time and your energy to keep
thinking about things that are outside
of your control now that we've
identified the triggers and we kind of
understand how to control them how do we
navigate those conversations and get the
most out of that feedback Douglas Stone
defines three phases of a feedback
conversation the open the body and the
clothes the open is before the content
of the feedback it's where you get
aligned with the other person by trying
to understand what kind of feedback is
this and what's the intent behind this
feedback is this evaluation is this
coaching is this appreciation and also
trying to understand who has the final
word and is this feedback negotiable if
you're working for someone your boss in
most cases has a final word
um no matter how right you think you are
in the end it does kind of come down to
this you are there by choice you know
you agree to the deal you work for them
and they are paying you to represent the
firm and obviously there's a lot of
nuance to this but that's the kind of
systems framework that you have to
consider and then there's the body the
body is the content of the feedback or
like the meat of the talk and to get the
most out of this feedback you need to
listen that's something that I'm really
really trying to work on try to really
pay attention to what the other person's
saying and while you're doing this
listen to your own internal voice and
try to watch for the triggers that we
talked about and then clarify you can
always ask for specificities or
specifics on expectations or
Consequences and you can also add your
own input and try to explain the
situation in your own thoughts and in
your observations you can also talk
about your interpretations on things or
your feelings you can also try to
referee the conversation try to diagnose
and describe the communication problems
as they come up so that you can kind of
propose Solutions in a real time and the
last stage of that is the close that's
where you clarify the commitment
treatments and expectations and the
follow-up you know who's gonna do what
specifically when you leave the meeting
are there like benchmarks or
Consequences if you don't meet those
benchmarks and are you going to be
having regular check-ins then the last
but the most important step is actually
incorporating the feedback try to focus
on one thing at a time or you know test
it with small experiments and make sure
you really really understand what the
other person is trying to say you can
give yourself rewards for making these
changes or you can also add consequences
for not making these changes also try to
make the other person feel valued by
taking their advice and later they are
gonna come to you for advice in
conclusion what's interesting but also
really true is that negative feedback if
you know how to handle it it can
actually have a much much more positive
impact on your life than positive impact
think about a architecture project right
if you get really really positive
feedback then at the end of the day it's
kind of hard to know where to take that
but when you have a really bad crit you
might cry but
you have so many different ways you can
take your project afterwards right so
try to really use this feedback to your
advantage and really make something of
it alright guys so I hope that was
helpful let me know if you have any
comments or questions or if you have any
strategies for dealing with negative
feedback if you like this video please
give me a thumbs up and if you like this
type of content subscribe to the channel
I'm always making videos once every week
also I have a Discord Channel if you
want to pop in there and ask questions
it's full of students and professionals
from all over the world and yeah with
that I'll see you guys in the next video
bye
foreign
[Music]
did you read the books I told you to
read